let's start with how does it look this
question stop a point P I knit mousse
such that now what I'm going to describe
is going to be very similar to the
straight line that we had before
okay so a streamline how do I get a
straight line like a perpendicular
bisector I say your one point here and
you've got another point Yeah right and
what's what's the wording that usually
gets it what what wedding
it's up yeah this point Rousseau it's
always the same distance from a heavy
okay I'm just going to modify that just
a little bit and you're gonna say we're
gonna get arrived at different shape
okay so at the end after you've worked
out the patient we're gonna lure it or
it might even you're gonna try one about
what it is so instead of equidistant
from two points where you'll say such
that it's distance from a
at this point is always not equal but
double
there's always double its distance
so there's my setup pick out the
important pieces right and then write
down an equation and see which of these
you'll need and then expand it up
simplify as far down as you can there's
some pretty tricky algebra because there
are some big things that you can get
squared out an expanded so be careful
okay and when you get to the end you
want to find the equation try and answer
the question what does you see look like
how would you describe its shape and
then lastly you can draw it yes Justin
not yet yeah and maybe you know but just
as a general rule right because I know
if all of your different places in terms
of how much you remember or how much
maybe you've seen in advance okay so if
you if I give you a question like this
right and you're like I know this one
okay um I sort of generally treat that
person don't take this personally it's
kind of like the person in the movie
theater who you know you've never seen
this movie before and this wasn't seen
like ten times before right and they're
in there like in the middle so everyone
can hear them and as someone comes up
like you see him for the first time and
they're like someone period you're not
sure about the and they seem to be a
good guy and then they whisper really
not like that's what I just wasted two
hours of my life okay and like in like
12 dollars because you know really
expensive yeah so what's the point
don't spoil it cuz it robs you not ever
cinematic experience but I'll try to
actually go through this yourself and
okay because what some spoil it for you
they've I told you right now it's a blah
available boring okay and less surprise
when you have to get there okay cuz
you'd expect it sounds very similar to
this but it's totally different
okay so off you go give it a go and then
mighty about a few minutes